the statue of koya shouki
[Music]
stephen mark
hi
what
okay so muna episode 4 probably has one
of the most head-scratching endings in a
tv show since before lost lost its
audience with its stupid final season
yes i'm still bitter what you doing what
the what the hell are you doing anyway
there's lots of things that could be
happening with this and the heavy
spoilers team have been talking every
week about where we think things are
going a huge shout out to our editor
matt for coming up with a theory that
the entire show is actually a show
within a show and though i initially
fired him at first i think the guy might
be right every week there's been more
and more evidence towards it and
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down with some of our
other theories about what's really
happening so sit back hold on to your
butt because sh is about to get weird
please hit the thumbs up button if you
enjoy the breakdown and also don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day without the way welcome to the
heavy spoiler show now let's make it
even stevens and get into the breakdown
okay so before we go over the evidence i
feel like we have to discuss how this
actually falls from the comics and what
they're doing in episode four jeff
lemire's run is pretty much the entire
basis for the twist and the entry and in
it mark finds himself inside an asylum
run by a character called dr emmett
revealed to actually be omit she uses
jackals disguised as orderlies to try
and convince mark that all his memories
of being mooned are fake and that he's
actually just imagined the entire thing
due to his psychosis eventually mark
breaks out the illusion and he discovers
that he's really trapped inside another
dimension known as the other void which
exists outside of time and space mark
and the rest of his personalities battle
their way out of this with us getting
the story told to us from different
perspectives firstly is mark who sees
himself being chased by mummies much
like what we got in episode 4. zorsa j
lockley who believes he's being framed
for murder and moon knight who thinks
he's a space pilot as steven believes
that he's actually a tv show producer
working on moon night and all of his
sections are told to us with him
believing he's on set shooting the show
so there's definitely precedent in the
comics to have all this just be part of
one big tv show and once you see the
evidence you might see how stuff
actually goes beyond this and the first
thing i want to talk about is the green
screen in episode three as many of you
know most of us break down punks got
sent the first four episodes early but
we were told the elements of them were
unfinished when we finally got around to
watching episode 3 last week i just
assumed that the bright green cloth that
was seen during one of the fight scenes
was something that they hadn't tied it
up yet and didn't bother to mention it
in our breakdown script however when the
episode released it stayed behind and
it's weird seeing a cloth is colour
because i don't think i've ever seen one
like this that you can buy as it's
pretty vomit inducing this green shade
is used in green screen because it's
rare that someone would ever wear
clothing that's this shade so seeing it
on a cloth is a bit weird and if you've
been paying attention to twitter you
might have also seen there was a
cameraman spotted in a shot during the
chase scene these two things are pretty
glaring when you're playing with this
theory and after re-watching episode 2
there's a massive moment that stood out
in it when stephen is fired from his job
at the museum the hr guy sits behind a
table that looks exactly like the one
that harrow has in episode 4. he also
passes him a leaflet for help another
face on it is extremely blurred it's
almost a double for how harrow appears
in the episode
shortly after this stephen talks about
the nhs and he also pays lip service to
having been in one of these hospitals
before much like what we see in episode
4. now the only way for this to all work
is if there's some truth to what's
happening in four and potentially either
the fourth wall will break and steven
will reveal he's a show producer slash
actor much like the comics or he'll be
in an institution now i received a
really observant email from someone
today who said they'd spent several
years as an in-n-out patient at mental
health facilities they said they felt
uncomfortable sharing this on social
media so i don't want to use the
person's name but i'll add it as a pin
comment if they get back to me and say
it's okay they noticed several things in
the series that also pop up in the
hospital that we didn't really pick up
in our initial breakdown the first being
that when stephen leaves his flat he
runs into a man with a cart full of
brooms and a pushcart like this is
almost a constant in a hospital setting
they also brought up the orderlies bobby
and billy who appear in the hospital and
also the comics when they took him to
harrow they unlocked his handcuffs and
harrow says he just wanted to better
understand the situation this entire
scene is the same way that a patient
would be introduced to their new home in
a hospital by their psychiatrist this
includes people sitting in the
background discussing things on
meditation pillows and also the area
with everyone watching calming nature
films a common practice is to give a
patient food from the same line as the
others to show it's a safe space which
is something that also happens now the
entire fourth episode could be an
allegory to mark working with layla to
get into parts of the hospital that he
shouldn't be in with harrow's words of
not being able to help someone that
can't help themselves it feels like he's
riffing on common practices used by
hospitals the death scene itself could
also be a metaphor for being sedated and
yet it all seems like that's the kind of
thing they're doing i'm not sure whether
we will completely go that way but it's
definitely worth talking about and i
kind of feel like more evidence will pop
up as we go back through the episodes
and we watch them and there's also the
third personality jake lockley who has
been teased a lot in the last four
episodes the latest one ends with mark
and steven being reunited and it seems
like jake is locked away at this point
but no doubt he'll come bounding out as
they rely on more personalities to help
them get out of there that's really
where i can see things going next time
and jake seems to be far more brutal
than the other two with them both
denying killing those kids in episode 3
it only leaves him as the guilty party
and we have had other hints towards him
i've already done the accent thing like
three times yet but i'll replay the clip
in case you didn't watch those videos
just so you can hear how it slightly
differs from marks i'm looking for send
food sarcophagus
what are you doing here you should be
here watching what this joker just puts
on normal mock games in his backyard for
fun looking for centuries sarcophagus
what are you doing here you should be
here
what this joker just puts on normal mock
games in his backyard for fun there was
also the taxi which jake drives and the
date from episode one mark is of course
married to layla and he was trying to
keep a low profile so i can't see him
organizing a night out with a woman at a
steakhouse if he was still trying to
keep things secret someone other than
stephen and mark organized this and
therefore i think that is probably jake
who did it rather than them so yeah
expect a big jake revealed pretty soon i
think and i can imagine that the next
episode will be pretty flashback heavy
as we delve into mark's psyche and learn
about his past his parents have already
been cast and with them being quite
young actors it seems the way they'll be
going is exploring what made him him and
him and possibly him trailers have shown
the faithful time that he became
conscious avatar and yeah i can't see
that being what we do next before we
ramp up for a big finale the week after
that now this will also allow them to
introduce rail bushman who has been
hinted at in the series in case you
don't know he's the guy who mark went to
the dig site with in which they honored
the temple of konchu realizing he could
get rich bushman killed everyone there
and then he beat mark within an inch of
his life mark was then taken before the
shrine of konchu and he agreed to become
his avatar on earth in exchange for
being brought back to life mark then
went after him and though he hasn't been
named specifically i do think it will be
revealed that bushman was behind leyla's
dad's death there are also a number of
theories saying that they think that
jake might actually be the assassin and
that he could be the one who killed her
dad it is a pretty good theory that
would put mark in an awkward position
and from the hints we've had of jake so
far he doesn't really mind killing
people however i'm still kind of tied to
the source material and i think that
they'll probably still go with bushman
now where we could go with layla is a
complete unknown but it does seem like
they might be teasing that she's the
scarlet scarab in the comics this was a
character known as abdul fal who dressed
up as a pharaoh and led a group known as
the sons of the scarab thaler's father
nicknamed her his little scarab and her
full name also sounds a lot like abdul
in episode three we learned it was layla
abdullah al fowley which does sound
quite similar to abdul fowl in episode 4
when we cut to her in the asylum she
also gets up close to mark and you can
actually make out a red scarab marking
on a thimble that she has on her finger
this definitely makes me think they're
teasing that she's going to get her own
powers in costume and the mcu is very
much leaning into women becoming supes
alongside the men layla is one of my
favorite characters so i'd love to see
it and with her not being based on
anyone from the comics he could
definitely do it and give us a big
surprise now the episode culminated with
tarouwek coming onto the scene and it
looks like she's either trapped down
there too or able to access it
potentially she was a god that oversaw
alexander's tomb or like konchu she
became trapped in a statue and has been
banished to wherever this is now her
showing up is clearly gonna be important
for how they escape and i kind of feel
like she might either make mark or
steven herravator going beyond that she
could make layla become one and this
could allow her to become the scarlet
scarab that we've been theorizing about
as for b22 it's still not exactly clear
what this number was included for and
the only things we've been able to link
it to is the fact that 22 isn't on the
bingo card and moonlight volume 22 in
which mark stephen and jake all made big
appearances as different personalities
now our editor mat went through the
numbers on the card and added them all
up and if you take b22 g15 07 b7 n39 and
i2 it all adds up to 174 the marvel
legacy numbering start at issue 188 and
if you subtract the issues to find what
should be 174 you end up with jeff
lemire issue 1 which is what this entire
thing is based on it's a pretty deep
good easter egg and beyond that all the
numbers that crawley calls out aren't
typical on a us card for bingo it's
somehow mark still wins kinda makes me
think that with the numbers all being
missing that the entire scenario is a
lie and something to show that the rules
of this place aren't based on reality
this is why the corridor shifts later on
and why we also get the other
personalities trapped there i kind of
feel like there might be a hidden
meaning behind it but right now we don't
really know however things might become
clear when we discover mark's past
potentially this is linked to his mother
who died when he was very young in the
comics though stephen grant has spent
time on the phone to his if she actually
existed she'd surely know that his voice
had changed quite a lot layla also asked
about his mother an episode too but this
could potentially just be a lie that
mark fetter in order to hide the truth
from her i definitely think there's more
than meets the eye with her that we will
likely explore as we get further into
the series we have just two episodes
left and what i love about the show is
that no one can say for definite exactly
where it's going so in conclusion the
whole thing might be doing crap cgi and
bad sets on purpose because it's
actually a tv show we're probably going
to be seeing jake lockley sooner rather
than later and laila might end up
becoming a character from the comics
that will mean she can do her own things
going forward lots of things to discuss
and i don't know if i'm wrong or if i'm
right but i just had to give my initial
theories after watching the whole thing
play out it's gonna be a long way for
episode 5 but in the meantime i'd love
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below you probably have
better ones than me so make sure you
drop them and call it before we get to
next week's entry now we are in
competition right now and giving away
three more copies of spider-man no way
home on the 15th of may and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
brighton of episode 4 in which we go
into way more detail that'll be linked
on screen right now so head over there
or else i don't know what i'm gonna do
but please please do i need the views
thanks a lot i'll see you next time take
care peace